Viel besser.
So.
Wunderbar, dann würde ich einfach dich bitten, das Jingle abzuspielen und dann geht's bei uns los.
Das ist konditioniert. Das Jingle läuft und Kieran muss anfangen zu lachen.
Ja, was ist das?
Das hat ich gesehen.
Okay, herzlich willkommen, liebe Zuhörer, Zuhörerinnen da draußen an die Live-Zuhörer und Zuhörerinnen,
besonders bei akronomisierbar Folge 36, passenderweise auf dem 36C3.
Das haben wir sogar fast nicht geplant.
Kehran und ich haben extra im Dezember keine Folge aufgenommen, damit wir das jetzt schaffen.
Ja, das hätten wir auch anderweitig nicht geschafft durch den 35.5 oder so.
Und das ist wieder mal eine sehr besondere Folge, denn wir haben wieder mal sehr, sehr viele Leute hier an diesem wunderschönen Tisch sitzen.
Also nochmal Kontext, wir sitzen gerade im Sendezentrum, man hört auch ein bisschen Kongress im Hintergrund.
Wir haben aber auch Publikum.
Wir haben ein wenig Publikum, Grüße an unser Publikum, schön, dass ihr dabei seid, freuen uns sehr.
Und wir sind hier im Sendezentrum am Sendetisch und an diesem wunderschönen Sendetisch sitzen dieses Mal
Henrik
Kilian
Steiger
Juvie
Sascha
Herzlich willkommen an diesem Tisch
So ein bisschen, genau
Und das First bei dieser Sendung ist, dass sich tatsächlich zum ersten Mal Juvie und Kilian begegnen
Wir haben so zwei Rotbärte an diesem Tisch
Ja, das ist jetzt eindeutig das Lieb
Das ist ja noch nordischer jetzt gerade, ja
Nice, schön dich kennenzulernen
Ja, ebenso
Ihr wart beide schon mutually exclusive
auf diesem Podcast vertreten?
Ja, wir waren auch beide schon
mutually exclusive im Maski.
Tja, siehst du mal.
Wir kennen uns schon sehr lange nicht.
Ja, genau.
Ja, aber wir sind ja auch im Kongress.
Das heißt, wir haben ganz viele tolle Leute um uns rum
und ganz viele tolle Talks und Assemblies
und andere Aufbauten und
viele
Seiten.
Was habt ihr hier schon so cooles gesehen?
Heute ist ja erst Tag 1. Wir legen ja gerade erst los hier.
Das heißt, man ist gerade erst mal angekommen.
Man lässt alles ein bisschen auf sich wirken.
Man verzweifelt leicht vor Awesomeness.
Man, keine Ahnung, stößt mit Bier hier an.
Anscheinend. Cheers.
Prost.
Prost dich jetzt erstmal.
Das Bier des Tages ist
Prämien.
Gut, bitte. Lass dich nicht unterbrechen von mir.
Ich wollte bloß endlich anfangen zu trinken.
Ich habe direkt vorhin, nachdem ich gekommen bin, erstmal eine Engelsschicht gemacht.
einfach mal so eine Low-Level-Access-Control-Schicht,
die natürlich auch relevant sind.
ACL-Enge.
Aber jetzt ohne hier viel Arbeit zu leisten.
Und da kamen trotzdem einfach coole Leute vorbei
und die hier, die wir haben.
Das fand ich einfach toll.
Das ist so lieb.
Das fand ich echt lieb.
Sie wollen nicht bloß abfüllen,
damit Sie die Abkürzung nehmen können.
Tja, so funktioniert das.
Zu bad, dass ich nicht mehr diese Schicht mache.
Gestern ist hier einer rumgelaufen,
die hatte so eine Box mit Cola-Gummis dabei
und hat so kleine Tütchen mit Cola-Gummis verteilt.
Als sie mir das erste Mal eine Hand gedrückt hat,
war ich erst so ein bisschen skeptisch.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Süßigkeiten von Fremden,
da haben mir meine Eltern früher etwas.
Und das habe ich dann aber sehr gerne angenommen.
Und dann habe ich die irgendwie eine halbe Stunde später,
ist dann wieder einer an mir vorbeigelaufen.
Ach, die kenne ich irgendwo.
Da hält die mir wieder eine Tüte Cola-Gummis entgegen.
Und ich denke so, warte mal, hier, ich habe noch eine von vorhin.
Ich habe die noch gar nicht oft gemacht.
Gibt die jemand anders?
Ich habe noch meinen Beleg.
Kann ich die umtauschen?
Ich habe es gestern ein bisschen übertrieben mit den Engelschichten.
Ich dachte so, na bevor es jetzt richtig losgeht,
machst du mal gleich ein paar Stunden auf dein Konto,
damit nächstes Jahr auch der Voucher wieder gesichert ist.
Und habe mir dann sechs Stunden hintereinander geklickt
von 22 bis 4 Uhr.
Sehr schön.
Ja, also meine Füße sind gerade noch so existent.
War zwei Stunden in der Garderobe,
Quatsch, vier Stunden in der Garderobe.
Das war sehr gut.
Wir waren vier Personen am Ende, glaube ich,
die drei Jacken bewacht haben.
Was ist irgendwie eine coole Erfahrung am Lost in Found, hast du gemeint?
Ach ja, genau.
Es gab ein paar witzige Dinge beim Lost & Found.
Also es gibt eine neue Software und die hatten halt schon ein paar Items angenommen,
aber noch nicht richtig die Software eingetragen,
weil die Software noch gerade live in der Entwicklung ist.
Also während ich da war in den vier Stunden wurden mehrere Bugs gepatcht.
Das ist Continuous Deployment, Mensch.
Ja, ja, absolut.
Inklusive, but it worked in Testing und in Produktion ist dann irgendwelche JavaScript-Fehler.
Wie heißt es? Testing und Production?
Ist es zwei in meinem Wunsch?
Ich staune auch, ja.
Und habe dann da so ein bisschen katalogisiert, was da so da war.
mir wurde halt einfach gesagt, wir machen hier Dienst
nach Vorschriften, mir wurde gesagt, alles was im Lost and Foundry
alles wird, katalogisiert und dann habe ich halt
katalogisiert, ja, so Schäler,
Jacken, Taschen, einzelne
Geldscheine, die abgegeben wurden.
Einzelne Geldscheine?
Aha, also muss ich dahin gehen, um meinen 50-Euro-Schein
zu haben?
Es kann tatsächlich sein, dass ein 50-Euro-Schein
da liegt, allerdings ist eine Doku dran,
wo die Geschichte dieses 50-Euro-Scheins
erklärt wird und das könnte man
zur Verifikation nutzen, ansonsten fällt das
dann wahrscheinlich dem Log zu irgendwann.
und unter anderem habe ich auch eine Holzschraube
inventarisiert.
Die lag da auch und es war ein Metallregal,
also es kann nicht zu dem Regal gehört haben.
Also habe ich die inventarisiert. Das wurde dann
von der
von der Garderoben-Orga
nicht so positiv gesehen. Der Eintrag wurde gelöscht
und die wurde im Papierkorb einsortiert.
Das ist nicht relevant.
In der Runterablage.
Holzschraube geht aber auch nicht in Papier.
Später kam dann ein Bürger an
und meinte so, ja, ich habe hier draußen
vorm Eingang eine Fundsache gefunden,
nämlich da stand einfach eine halbe Flasche Bier.
Ich möchte die gerne abgeben.
Ich dachte, der kam an und hat gesagt,
ich suche ganz dringend eine Holzschraube.
Er hätte auch ein halbes Bier suchen können.
Aber ich glaube, ich gehe nachher
mit einem Los & Paun vorbei und frage,
ob mein Bier gefunden wurde.
Du kannst einen Suchauftrag aufgeben lassen.
Nein.
Dann ruft man dich auf deinem Bett an,
wenn es wieder da ist.
Ich habe dann Ihnen doch geraten,
das vielleicht doch einfach im Ausfluss zu kippen
und in den Bottledrop-Point zu stellen,
das wäre dann doch vielleicht ein besserer
Actionplan. Ja, also nichts gegen
Premium-Bier, aber wenn es eine Weile irgendwo stand,
dann war es Premium-Bier.
Das trifft ja auf jedes Bier zu,
ob da nun Premium draufsteht oder nicht.
Wenn das eine halbe Stunde irgendwo gestanden ist,
ist jedes Bier nicht mehr so Premium.
Dann kannst du es schon bei den
Schälern einsortieren.
Tja, da haben wir uns heute Frühjahr knapp verpasst,
denn ich wollte eigentlich um vier aufstehen,
habe es dann irgendwann auch geschafft,
bin mit dem Zug hergefahren
Genau und
ja, irgendwie
dreimal Update installieren ist man
in Leipzig von Tosteins, absolut super
Und mit Updates über so WiFi?
ICE oder was? Over the Handy
Achso, du bist ja super. Genau, dreimal
Updates installieren. Windows-Updates?
Einmal war überhaupt ein bisschen rieser und dann
naja
Hast du noch von vorne angefangen? Dann bin ich ja angekommen, da war es
irgendwie so 5.30 Uhr
Ne, Quatsch, 6.30 Uhr
und es war
absolute Stille, alles aufgebaut wie so
Stillleben, das ist unglaublich.
Man hätte eine Holzschraube fallen.
Man hätte eine Holzschraube fallen gehört.
Man hörte bloß still, wie ein Bier in den Abguss gegossen worden.
Wir haben übrigens gerade eine Führung.
Es haben sich gerade gefühlte 30 Menschen hinter uns versammelt.
Ich fühle mich leicht beobachtet.
Ich muss es auch.
Ah, okay.
Weg mit dem Bier.
Weg mit dem Bier, raus mit den Holzschrauben.
Achso, wir müssen jetzt das Bier verstecken.
Aber das alles nur an Tag 1
Wir haben ja den Großteil des Kongresses noch gar nicht
Wir haben ja noch nicht mal Bergfest erlebt
Wer war von euch als allererstes
eigentlich jetzt hier?
Ich war gestern 15 Uhr da
Ich auch
Warum habe ich dich nicht gesehen?
Ich glaube es waren gestern 15 Uhr bereits
3000 Menschen hier
Ich glaube Dirk können wir eh nicht toppen
Ne, der ist schon eine Weile hier
Wann ist der aufgekreuzt?
Das darf ich nicht sagen
Okay.
Es gab sicherlich auch mehr als genug Leute, die hier da waren,
bevor sie dann zum Weihnachten gefahren sind.
Aufbau ist ja schon irgendwie seit dem Anfang 20...
Nee, schon eine Weile.
18. mindestens.
18. krass.
Nikonus, Schuhe putzen.
Ja, geht ja schon eine Weile.
Ist ja auch immens, was hier mal aufgebaut wird.
Und ich meine, die gerade die Assembly-Hallen sehen unglaublich aus.
Was ich immer am faszinierendsten finde, ist, wie schnell der Abbau ist.
Du kommst so aus der Closing-Ceremony raus und gehst in die Halle 2 und fast alles ist weg.
Das ist wie unglaublich.
Das ist noch lange hin.
Ich kann mich erinnern, das letzte Mal, als wir in Hamburg waren.
Tschüss, Jugendakt.
Ciao.
Das letzte Mal in Hamburg mussten wir noch in derselben Nacht raus.
Da war auch ganz schöne Abrissstimmung.
Nach dem letzten Talk waren schon die Hälfte der Sachen
oder ein Großteil von den Sachen abgebaut.
Und dann ist jeder, der raus ist,
hat noch schnell ein paar Sachen unter den Armen mitgenommen.
Abrissstimmung ist voll on the nose.
Das letzte Mal in Hamburg.
Ja, genau.
Das letzte Mal war nicht am nächsten Tag
direkt mit den Baggern angerückt oder sowas.
Das war die Closing-Ceremony. Jeder nimmt bitte
seinen Sitz mit.
Also ich glaube, das hätten manche Leute
fast gemacht. Ja, aber können wir
jetzt eigentlich noch so viel mehr über diesen Kongress erzählen?
Weil er hat ja quasi gerade erst angefangen.
Ich war heute ehrlich gesagt
in exakt einem Talk.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Wir waren zusammen in zwei Talks.
Ach stimmt, wir waren vorher
in diesem PSD-2-Talk.
Erzähl mal.
Den wollte ich mir anhören, habe ich aber verpasst.
Wie war der denn?
Zusammenfassung ist, früher war alles auch scheiße,
aber jetzt ist es noch schlimmer.
Ja gut, das ist ja nichts Neues.
Das trifft ganz gut.
Es gibt so Screenshots von Leuten, die irgendwie 5, 6, 7,
2-Factor-Apps von jeder Bank installiert haben.
Was ich sehr beeindruckend fand, ist, dass es sehr viel
gerante über Sofortüberweisung war, was ich verstehen kann
und auch legitim finde, weil der Service ist absolut scheiße.
Aber am Ende in der Frage Q&A hat sich einer
als Sofortüberweisungsmitarbeiter geoutet.
Das war Mut.
Das war so reminiscent von den Leuten,
die am Ende von diesen Pearl Jam Talks
reden.
Aber warte mal,
das ist meine Sprache.
Ist doch nicht alles schlecht.
Ich weiß schon, dass einer von dir am Tisch sitzt.
Was?
Stefan, also bitte.
Und sogar gleich der erste Kommentar auf dem ersten Pearl Jam Vortrag war von mir.
Echt? Du hast gesagt, ich benutze Pearl?
Ich habe Pearl
drei Jahre lang auf Arbeit gemacht.
Und ich war sehr froh damit.
gleich nochmal die Aufzeichnung an. Wenn du ins 29 zu 3
Hacker-Jeopardy gehst, gab es eine Kategorie
Pearl-Operatoren und bei der
500er-Frage gab es keinen, der erklären
konnte, was das Ding macht, außer mir.
Sag mal, gehst du eigentlich dieses Jahr zum Hacker-Jeopardy?
Schaffst du das jetzt?
Bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt wieder Willens noch eine Lage
genau zahlen zu nennen. Also was ich auf jeden Fall sagen kann,
ist, wenn ich die dieses
Mal gewinne, dann ist das von langer Hand geplant
und soll meine absolute Dominanz zementieren.
Wenn ich verliere, ist es
auch von langer Hand geplant, weil
als Champion habe ich das Problem, ich kann nur
in einer Runde teilnehmen. Ich kann nicht an der
Vorrunde teilnehmen. Okay, also du musst
definitiv teilnehmen, weil du Champion bist, oder wie?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ich habe keine
Kommunikation erhalten, aber ich werde dann
in der Finalrunde einfach es genauso machen, wie
letztes Mal in der ersten Runde, dass ich
einfach auf den Tisch hingehe und
so tue, als gehöre ich einfach dazu.
Was haben wir dir gerade gezeigt bekommen?
Ich meine, gewunken. Achso.
Ich habe gestern
gestern stand ich in der Schlange
zu den Waffeln
Am Waffel-Operation-Center.
Und da stand vor mir einer, der auch gemeint hat,
ich muss unbedingt zum Hacker-Jabber-D.
Da war letztens ja einer, wie ist denn der?
Xyrick, irgend sowas.
Der hat übel abgeräumt.
Aber das stimmt auch.
Das war schon hart dazu.
Am meisten habe ich ja Respekt eingeflößt,
die LATCH-Session.
Das ist aber bei allen so.
Das fand ich aber wunderbar.
Also wirklich so LATCH-Bummeln im Kopf setten.
Die Berechnung war jetzt nicht das Komplizierte,
mehr als im Kopf schnell, warte,
das Typesetting machen.
Naja, das habe ich halt damals in Physikstudien gemacht.
Mit zwei Leuten zusammen haben wir
die ganzen Vorlesungen alle live mitgeschrieben.
Sie akkumulieren über 34, 33,
32.
Ja, wir haben es diskutiert.
Wechseln wir mal
ein wenig das Thema.
Kongress ist eine Zeit im Jahr,
wo viel passiert. Weihnachten ist gerade vorbei.
Aber eigentlich auch der gesamte
Rest vom Jahr ist auch so ziemlich vorbei.
Es sind nur noch wenige
Tage bis Silvester.
Und deswegen würde ich gerne diese Runde mal
traditionell nutzen und mit euch ein bisschen
reden. Was ist denn
irgendwie 2019 überhaupt alles passiert?
Es ist so schnell vorbei gewesen irgendwie.
Was sind eure fünf
Top-Themen?
Habt ihr sowas überhaupt? Kriegt ihr das spontan
irgendwie zusammen?
Das haben ein paar Leute was ins Bett geschrieben.
Pst!
So viel zu spontan.
Also ich habe tatsächlich spontan nichts.
Du hast das
vorhin irgendwie nach Punkt 3
boykottiert.
Punkt 3 ist, glaube ich, nicht politisch korrekt.
Ich lese den jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht vor.
Ja, aber das lag daran, dass Lukas neben mir saß.
Und Lukas meint, dass Österreicher besser Deutsch sprechen, weil Lukas aus Österreich kommt.
Wenn du Punkt 3 nicht korrekt findest, lies bitte Punkt 1 genauso vor.
Warrior ist jetzt eine scheiß US-Firma.
Ich kann es nicht nehmen.
So war das nicht gemeint.
Ne, was ist denn dieser Passiv? Keine Ahnung. Klemm mich mal bitte auf.
Also ich mache mal eine kleine persönliche Zusammenfassung.
Akronomisierbar hat dieses Jahr inklusive dieser
neun Folgen aufgenommen.
Das ist eine ziemlich schlechte
Quote.
Ein wöchentlicher Podcast sind, ja,
das sind sehr schlechte Quote. Ja, der wöchentliche Podcast
mit genau neun Wochen pro Jahr.
Es sind ja noch vier weitere Tage
im Jahr drin.
Wir können ja noch ein paar
Folgen von Steigers Podcast
einfach umbranden.
Das steht auf meiner Liste.
Wie viel Aufwand ist es denn,
das wöchentlich zu machen.
Das war nicht geplant als wirklicher Podcast.
Wir haben am Anfang mal gesagt,
wir machen das wöchentlich und dann haben wir uns ganz kurz gegenseitig
eingebunden und gedacht, skaliert das
überhaupt? Schaffen wir das?
Ich glaube, dann machst du das auch beruflich,
wenn du das wöchentlich machst.
Also das haben wir nicht
geschafft, aber ich glaube, die Frequenz, die wir haben,
ist einigermaßen, ich meine, wir machen es ja wirklich
zum Spaß und
wir haben keinen Schedule, wir machen
eine Folge auf Zugriff
und dann erinnere ich uns
chat immer mal wieder dran, komm lass uns mal wieder eine Folge machen
und Kehran sagt, oh ja.
Ja genau. Ich meine, auch als Hörer muss man
ja irgendwie so diese anderthalb
Stunden Audio-Shit-Posting irgendwie ertragen
können, es geht halt nur.
Die Hörer müssen sich immer erstmal wieder erholen.
Du könntest natürlich auch sagen,
machen einfach jede Woche, aber dafür halt nur eine Stunde.
Wenn du dann schneller
durchkommst.
Aber du kennst die beiden schon, dass die sich kurz
fassen, ist doch eher sehr. Wir machen einfach
jeden Tag eine 5-Minuten-Folge, Kehran.
Jeden Tag. Oh, finde ich gut.
Ich schicke dir eine Sprachnachricht, du schick dir eine Sprachnachricht.
Hier ist daily numisierbar.
Das klingt so ein bisschen wie der Instagram-Channel, den ich immer mal aufmachen möchte.
Ja, akkondisierbar Instagram-Channel.
Ihr habt einen Instagram-Channel.
Ja, ein totaler Instagram-Channel.
Sorry, ich habe mich nicht verunterbrochen.
Es gibt ja so viele Leute, die Fotos von ihrem Essen posten.
Ich finde das immer so ein bisschen nervig.
Du sitzt am Tisch, jeder packt sein Handy aus und macht erstmal ein Foto von seinem Essen.
Ich fände es viel besser, mal Bilder danach zu machen.
einfach den leeren Teller, zack.
Achso, ich dachte, du meinst das andere.
Oh Gott, nein.
Warte, das waren Bohnen.
Okay, wir haben ein
lokales Niveau tief erreicht.
Ich wechsle mal, stellen wir das Thema.
Punkt zwei auf meiner Liste ist...
Ist das doch auch Freitag, oder nicht?
Ist heute Freitag? Weißt du, wie du Leute richtig irritieren kannst,
wenn du auf einen Kongress mit Wochentagen kommst?
Ich merke es.
Das ist ein Konzept.
Ich übernachte beim Kongress häufig bei meinen Eltern
und die haben dann irgendwann,
kurz bevor ich losgefahren bin, haben sie gesagt,
wir sind glaube ich noch bis Samstag da und ich so,
warte mal, welcher Kongresstag
ist das?
Das wird ja noch schlimmer dadurch, dass du Weihnachten
davor hast, wo das auch alles zusammenbricht,
wenn du Feiertage dazwischen hast.
Es gibt Tag 1 bis 4 und eine andere Rechnung kenne ich nicht.
Genau.
Bitte nur Zeitdistanz rektoren.
Ja, genau.
Relativ zum Kongress.
Wir sind Tag 273,
das heißt minus...
Weihnachten ist dann Tag minus drei.
Vorsicht, nächstes Jahr ist Schaltjahr.
Oh Gott.
Das ändert aber die Distanz
zwischen Weihnachten, Neujahr
und Kongress nicht, oder?
Nee, aber wenn du jetzt
sagst, wir sind bei Tag sowieso, also
Tag minus sowieso, dann musst du aufpassen im Zweifelsfall.
Ja, aber
auch nur vorm Februar.
Womöglich.
Punkt zwei
auf meiner Liste.
Punkt zwei auf meiner Liste, es war irgendwie für mich
war 2019 das Jahr der Meetups,
weil ich habe ja schon länger
dieses semi-erfolgreiche Rust-Meetup
am Start. Es hat ein paar Mal
funktioniert dieses Jahr. Ich war aber auch
irgendwie selber Gast bei mehreren anderen und habe
meinen WebAssembly-Talk
ein bisschen durch die Gegend getragen und habe den
insgesamt glaube ich dreimal
gehalten. Einmal auf Arbeit und zweimal
bei unseren entsprechenden Meetups.
Nicht einmal beim Rust-Meetup.
Das steht noch aus.
Genau, und wir
organisieren jetzt auch eins lokal bei uns
in der Firma, ein WebAssembly.
Quatsch. Nein. Das kann sein.
Web-Scheiß. Das wird gehyptisch. Alles gleich.
Ein Web-RTC-Meetup.
Das war super schlecht.
Unterstützt die Firma das dann auch so im Sinne
von Recruiting oder ist das
für euch so eine Hobby-Veranstaltung,
wo die Firma einfach die Räumlichkeit
stellt? Wir sind eigentlich mit Meetup.
Da gab es doch auch irgendwie Stress bei dem Laden.
Meetup und WeWork.
Ja, eben. Läuft das jetzt nochmal weiter?
Oder muss ich da Geld bezahlen, wenn ich mich anmelde?
WeWork hat ein Meetup gekauft,
damit sie tatsächlich
noch so ein bisschen ihre Spaces
quasi nutzen können für Meetups,
damit die gleich zusammen angeboten werden.
Damit sie möglichst viele Dinge
mit in den Abgrund reißen können.
Im Prinzip ist das passiert.
Die Firma ist ja auch wirklich so.
Also wirklich gestiegen bis zum Wettnichtmehr
überall in aller Munde gewesen und plötzlich so,
oh fuck, wir haben mitgekriegt, die Firma macht ja gar nichts.
Was macht denn WeWork?
Na, WeWork vermietet Büroräume.
Das heißt, die kaufen Immobilien in bester Lage,
die natürlich außerordentlich teuer sind
und versucht dann da drin, Büroräume zu vermieten.
Das Problem, an dem die da, glaube ich, gescheitert sind,
das Ganze funktioniert natürlich nur mit Scale.
Das Ganze scheitert aber auch ganz schnell an Scale,
weil wenn du einfach zu viel Platz hast,
den du nicht vermietet kriegst,
naja, dann ist das halt ein bisschen groß.
Deswegen haben sie Mieter gekauft.
Und die haben wohl sehr, sehr viel Leerstand
auf diesen Büroflächen gehabt.
Das ist ein Business, das kannst du machen.
Es gibt ja auch andere Player in dem Bereich,
also Regis oder so heißt da eine Firma,
die sowas anbietet, was halt dasselbe Geschäftsmodell ist,
weil der Proposition von WeWork ist ja,
dass du halt nicht einen bestimmten Ort buchst.
Du buchst halt nicht deinen Tisch in Dresden,
sondern du buchst halt einen Tisch bei WeWork
und wenn du jetzt halt morgen wie in Barcelona bist,
dann bist du halt da auch bei WeWork.
Und das kannst du aber halt bei anderen Firmen auch haben
und wenn du dann wie die anderen Firmen dir anguckst,
dann sind die halt gesund und munter und alles
und haben halt aber zehnmal weniger Valuation
für dieselbe Menge von Assets, die sie haben.
Und wenn WeWork jetzt halt einfach nur ein Zehntel so groß gewesen wäre,
wäre wahrscheinlich ja noch alles okay gewesen,
aber das war halt so ein CEO, der da halt eine Religion aufmachen wollte.
Wachstum!
Ja, nicht nur Wachstum, sondern so quasi,
wir lösen jetzt hier alle Probleme, die die Welt jemals hatte,
durch Kollaboration und haste nicht gesehen.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen arg over the top,
Ja, ja, das war sehr skurril.
Und ist dann natürlich dann, als dann jemand hinter die Fassade gepuckt hat,
weil sie öffentlich an die Börse gehen wollten,
dann gibt es ja das entsprechende Paperwork und dann sehen die Leute plötzlich,
da ist ja gar nichts dahinter.
Und dann ist das wie so ein Soufrien sich zusammengefallen.
Die Firma macht ja gar nichts.
Das passiert, wenn der Kuh zu früh ansticht.
Sie machen was, aber sie machen nicht was im Wert von 100 Milliarden Euro.
Genau, und ich glaube, das ist auch ein Problem,
was ein Stück weit auch mit den Investoren zusammenhängt, die in sowas investieren.
weil ich habe sehr stark den Eindruck, dass wir momentan da schon auch so eine,
ich nenne das mal Startup-Blase haben, auch wenn ich mich schwer damit tue,
so eine Firma wie WeWork oder Uber, die irgendwie im Bereich hunderter Milliarden bewertet werden,
noch als Startup zu bezeichnen.
Unicorn.
Ja, nee, das nennt man doch mittlerweile irgendwie Hexa-Unicorn.
Was weiß ich, da gibt es einen neuen Begriff, weil Unicorn ist ja nur eine Milliarde.
und dadurch, dass du ja für Geld
keine Zinsen mehr kriegst, brauchen reiche
Leute halt irgendwas, womit sie
zocken können.
Nicht mal reiche Leute, wenn du
ein Rentenfonds bist und du kannst halt
mit den konservativen Einlagen plötzlich nur noch
0,5% Zinsen machen.
Aber Rentenfonds hat eventuell Auflagen,
dass man sowas gar nicht investieren darf.
Wir sind feier Rentenfonds angekommen.
Oh Gott, wir werden älter.
Ich investiere ausschließlich in hochwertige
Bratenfonds.
Die hellen oder die dunklen?
Ich werde doch jetzt nicht meine Anlagestrategie
diskutieren. Was ist denn sonst
noch so 2019 passiert?
Eine Sache, die sehr auf
Twitter hin und her gegangen ist, ist
Slack hat sein Logo gewechselt. Das war für mich
ein Highlight dieses Jahr. Oder ein Lowlight.
Oder ein Lowlight.
Naja, ich habe jetzt auf meiner
Taskleiste immer diese Swastika mit dem
Regenbogenfarben rundherum.
Schön, dass du es gesagt hast, sonst hätte ich sagen müssen.
Regenbogen-Svastika ist aber auch echt so ein
Standalone-Begriff.
Würde ich sagen, haben wir eigentlich schon einen Folgentitel.
Oh Gott, das können wir nicht
publischen.
Gut, okay, weiter.
Da muss ich eigentlich jetzt mal outen, dass ich das nicht mal mitgekriegt
habe.
Aber unabhängig davon, es ist einfach eines von
diesen generischen Swirl-
Regenbogen-Logos. Sieht genauso aus wie das
Fotos-Logo
von Apple-Fotos.
genauso aus. Das Chrome-Logo ist
nicht weit davon weg.
Kannst du es noch Windows sagen?
Das Google-Logo. Vielleicht gibt es einfach nur
so und so viele Varianten, vier Farben nebeneinander
anzuordnen in einem quadratischen Logo.
Gibt es bestimmt einen mathematischen Beweis.
Vier-Farben-Satz?
Gibt es vielleicht schon. Aber ich glaube, der Raum
ist langsam erschöpft.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall gute Nachrichten für alle Leute,
die es nicht gesehen haben.
Ihr könnt auch alle im Slack-Design-Team
anfangen. Die haben es auch nicht gesehen.
Haben sie irgendwann mal
Ups, wir haben gar nicht gesehen, dass da ein Hackenkreuz in unserem Logo ist.
Ich glaube, das solltest du nicht machen, wenn du PR machst.
Ups, wir haben Mist gemacht.
Das kann man alles eleganter ausdrücken, denke ich.
Ich erinnere mich an so eine Übung in dem Modul Mediengestaltung,
wenn du Medieninformatiker der TU Dresden studierst,
wo man so einfach ganz allererste Übung,
du hast Tintenkleckser auf Papier gemalt.
Das war schon mal so ein ganz anderes Konzept.
Also es war so wirklich so, du malst haufenweise Linien und Tintenkleckser
und am Ende machst du ganz kurz den Hakenkreuz-Check,
dass du nicht irgendwo aus dem Hakenkreuz hingemalt hast.
Das war halt offiziell so vom Prof gesagt.
Machen wir kurz Sicherheitshalber den Hakenkreuz-Check.
Okay, passt.
Vielleicht ist das aber auch was sehr Deutsches.
Vielleicht kriegt der Amerikaner das auch einfach nicht beigebracht,
da den Hakenkreuz-Check zu machen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was sehen Sie hier?
Ein Hakenkreuz, ein Hakenkreuz.
Herr Höcke, setzen Sie sich endlich wieder hin.
Das war auch tatsächlich heute Morgen im Zug
eins meiner Highlights des Tages.
Ich habe irgendwie so ein Memen-Video gesehen,
von Weihnachten, wie so ein Kind
in Frankreich sein
Weihnachtsgeschenk auspackt
und das Kind wollte wohl Minecraft haben
von seinem Opa.
Der Opa hat da den Kampf verstanden
und das Kind packt dieses Buch aus.
Der Vater guckt so, was ist das denn?
Minecraft.
Okay, nächstes Thema
bitte.
Es ist ja auch sehr viele positive Sachen passiert.
Ich war auf einzelnen Demos,
wo ich mich teilweise
etwas alt gefühlt habe. Allerdings
möchte ich sagen, das ist ein gutes Zeichen für die nach
uns folgende Generation. Dieses Jahr
gab es sehr viele Fridays for
Future Demos. Ich weiß gar nicht, ging das in 2019
los oder gab es die schon 2018?
Die wurden auf jeden Fall in diesem
Jahr sehr, sehr groß.
Greta Thunberg ist auf der
Times die Person des Jahres
geworden. Sehr schönes Zeichen.
Auch positiv für Dresden. Es gab eine
unteilbare Demo mit unglaublich
vielen Teilnehmern. Weiß man, wie immer es waren?
40.000 oder so was.
So mit 30 hatte man gerechnet und 40 waren es zum Schluss.
Wenn man das Time Magazine Cäsar wählt, ist das dann der Time New Roman?
Des Weiteren gab es Demos gegen Artikel 13.
Als Showmeister-Fraut.
Mach die Schriftarten dann irgendwie dazu.
Also allgemein doch ein sehr positiv angehauchtes Jahr, was das angeht.
Du bist ein sehr optimistischer Mensch.
Du könntest auch sagen, das Leben ist total schrecklich, weil diese Demos existieren müssen.
Und insbesondere, was war das Ergebnis bei Artikel 13?
Nicht so geil.
Was war das Ergebnis von Fridays for Future bis jetzt?
Ein richtig ambitioniertes Klimapaket.
Das muss noch besser werden.
Du kannst das sagen, ohne zu lachen.
Die Politiker sind halt insgesamt 30 Jahre älter als die Leute, die durch die Straße gehen.
Aber immerhin interessiert sich die junge Generation für diese Themen.
Und da finde ich einfach, mir ist es scheißegal, wo mein iPhone herkommt und wie viel CO2 dabei produziert.
Ich habe heute extrem gestaunt, als es so durch die Nachrichten durchgescrollt war,
dass da so ein Headline war, dass laut einer Umfrage 60% der Deutschen befürworten würden,
aus Umweltschutzgründen das Silvesterfeuerwerk zu verbieten.
Oh, bitte.
In China ist das bereits passiert.
So eine schöne Idee.
Ich habe heute ein Bild gesehen von einem Aufsteller vor einem Obi-Markt,
wo wir aus Klimaschutzgründen verkaufen wir dieses Jahr keinen oder verzichten wieder auf Silvesterfeuerwerks.
Ja, das war dann auch so in dem Artikel, dass sich jetzt alle möglichen Einzelhändler überbieten,
das jetzt als Signaling nicht mehr im Sortiment zu haben,
aber wohl viele das nicht hinbekommen haben, weil sie halt schon die Orders schon vor Monaten platziert hatten.
Und dann ist es halt da und dann kann man es jetzt auch nicht irgendwie wegwerfen oder verbrennen.
Kannst du ja auch mal hinter dem Aufhaben bringen.
Aber es ist ein wunderschönes Statement, das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Ohne Witz, auf dem Weg hierher
bin ich kurz
über das Gelände gelaufen und hinter dem
Bauhaus
an der Messe
ging Feuerwerk auf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Restfeuerwerke schon mal losgeworden sind,
damit sie es nicht verkaufen müssen, aber da lief
auf jeden Fall einen minutenlangen Feuerwerk.
Das Bauhaus macht jedes Jahr extra für den Kongress
ein Feuerwerk und keine Sau kriegt mit, weil wir alle hier drin kommen.
Ich geh auch nicht mal mit, wenn es
wahr erhält wird. Echt wahr.
Naja, vor allen Dingen ist das ja auch
mittlerweile irgendwie dazu verkommen,
dass alle da ihre
Munition verballern in den ersten
zwei Minuten nach Neujahr und dann
siehst du ja eh nichts mehr,
weil dann alles irgendwie nur
so ein grauer, stinkender
Schleier ist.
Also da fände ich
es dann schöner, wenn es irgendwie vielleicht mal
ein schönes, offizielles Feuerwerk
gibt oder so. Das kann man ja trotzdem
mal noch machen.
Ich war glaube ich zweimal Silvesterfeiern
auf der Carola-Brücke in Dresden
und man außer
die Leute, die drei Meter um einen
rumstanden, hat man wirklich nicht
viel gesehen. Also ich sehe, ich habe jetzt absolut
nichts verpasst die letzten Jahre. Meine Strategie
war immer nach dem Kongress einfach nach Hause zu fahren
und dann am 31. September einfach
ins Bett zu gehen und am 1. Januar
wieder aufzustehen. Das ist ja die Kongresse
durch Jahrhundert. Ja, genau.
Nach etwa 20 Stunden Schlaf wieder aufstehen
und
bringt. Und dann guckst du kurz aus dem Fenster
und gehst gleich ins Bett. Genau.
Das ist ja wunderbar. Ich finde es
super unangenehm, durch die Straßen zu gehen, weil es halt
so unglaublich gefährlich ist, wie die Leute damit umgehen
und halt wirklich auf andere Leute zählen.
Das ist ekelhaft. PSA
auf jeden Fall niemals
wie Hendrik am Elbufer feiern in Dresden.
Das ist gefährlich.
Das sind Kinder, die einfach mal einen Böller nach hinten
in die Menge werfen. Alter.
Also ich habe einmal den Fehler gemacht,
am Marienplatz in München
den Wester zu feiern. Und dann ist es wirklich
ein Platz voller Menschen und so
fünf vor zwölf spaltet sich das plötzlich auf
beide Seiten auf und dann packen Leute
so Schirme aus, die sie vor sich halten und
beschießen sich gegen seine Raketen. Das war so unglaublich
bescheuert. Also irgendwie vorher die
Schirme mit Kevlar bespannt?
Das war so unglaublich. Ich frage mich
mal, was dann ist mit den Leuten, die aus Syrien
geflüchtet sind und sowas dann miterleben.
Bescheuert, diese Westeuropäer.
Unglaublich.
Gut, also man merke
sich, also es gibt noch Hoffnung für die Zukunft
für die Jugend, aber es sind auch alle bekloppt.
Gute Zusammenfassung.
Die Zukunft ist auch nicht mal das, was sie mal war.
Früher war mehr da,
das ist schöner.
Früher war mehr Zukunft.
Das schreiben wir auf dem T-Shirt.
Okay.
Ohne, dass wir jetzt weiterhin
über Silvester reden wollen, was noch ein Punkt war,
der irgendwie jetzt, um es wieder auf ein technisches Thema
zu bringen, für mich dieses Jahr signifikant war.
Microsoft stellt die eigene Entwicklung an Edge ein und rebrandet einfach Chromium und verkauft das als das neue Edge.
Ich erinnere mich, wir hatten noch letztes Jahr schon mal drüber gesprochen.
War das letztes Jahr schon Thema?
War das schon Thema, weil sie es angekündigt hatten.
Jetzt ist es ja wirklich Realität.
Ich habe die ersten Edge schon in der Hand gehalten und ich habe schon in diesem Podcast darüber geredet.
Und ich muss dreimal hingucken, um zu sehen, dass es nicht Chrom ist.
Aber ich setze noch einen drauf.
Heute gab es eine Headline.
Jeff Atwood hat es zumindest geteilt und für einen kurzen
offenbar geglaubt.
Es gibt nicht nur die Edge-Ium, es gibt auch noch
Safari-Ium. Nein, das ist fake.
Es gab heute die Headline, dass Safari
angeblich mit dem Gedanken spielt,
auf Chrome zu steigen. Das ist fake.
Dann warte ich
jetzt nur noch auf Firefox-Ium.
Firefox-Ium.
Das wäre aber, glaube ich, alles
fatal.
Google hat ja wirklich
die Entwicklung
der Engine in der Hand.
Ich zitiere mich selbst von ziemlich genau vor einem Jahr an diesem Tisch.
Dann hätten wir eine Linux-Körnel-artige Situation im Web.
Dann ist Chrome quasi der Linux-Körnel des Webs.
Alle entwickeln dran mit.
Ja, da ist aber, glaube ich, ein großer Unterschied.
Und das darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Der Linux-Körnel ist echtes Open Source.
Chrome ist ein Google-Projekt.
Da steht zwar außen Open Source drauf,
aber wenn denen dein Comment nicht gefällt,
dann kommt der da auch nicht rein.
Dann kannst du forken, wenn du willst.
Aber das musst du dann halt auch maintainen.
Ja, völlig offensichtlich, was zu tun ist.
Wir müssen einfach Chromium in die Linux-Foundation rein donaten.
Guck mal, da hat jemand sich ein Lebenswerk ausgesucht.
Nee, nee, das kann auch Linux-Torvalz maintainen.
Das ist eh alles nur Delegation.
Ich glaube, das ist aber auch nicht die Lösung,
weil Kubernetes ist ja auch in die Linux-Foundation rein donatet
und das ist auch ein sehr stark von Google durchzogenes Projekt.
Computing Foundation, die zu Linux Foundation
gehört, genau.
Also Open Source
ist schwer.
Und wir halten mehrere
Browser-Engines. Vorerst.
Sonst können wir
das mit dem Internet auch aufgeben.
Also ich gebe
diesen Blog-Found mal zu Protokoll.
Ich muss, wie gesagt, also ich spoiler,
das ist
nicht nur dementiert, sondern
scharf von
Apple-Contributern, also von Safari-Entwicklern
implementiert worden, aber ich gebe diesen Artikel
trotzdem mal zu Protokoll und ich meine, ein paar
von den Punkten, die hier aufgezählt werden, sind
ja gar nicht mal so dumm.
Für Apple wäre es
prinzipiell
nicht doof zu sagen, wir
entwickeln nicht mehr einen eigenen Browser.
Aber Apple ist ein Konkurrent von
Google. Ja, und sie haben die Ressourcen dazu.
Ist es doch nicht irgendwie schwer,
WebKit zu, also klar, du hast Leute, die das
WebKit maintainen über die Jahre, aber das ist ja nicht so, als ob Apple
daran scheitert, WebKit zu maintainen.
Vor allen Dingen haben sie ja mit WebKit
die Hoheit auf den iOS-Devices
und wenn du einen anderen Browser
auf ein iOS-Device bringen möchtest,
dann kannst du gerne dein UI
auf so ein Webkit draufklatschen, aber die
Engine darfst du nicht anfassen.
Das würden sie damit aufgeben, wenn sie
auf einen Chromium wechseln.
Es glaube ich nicht, dass das passieren wird.
Naja, gut. Ja, durchaus.
Ich gebe dir recht. Es gibt halt trotzdem
immer wieder Stellen, wo du merkst,
das geht nicht in Safari, das geht nicht in Safari.
Es sind halt an vielen
Webstandards, die rauskommen, so ein bisschen
die Bremser. Und das
ist nicht immer unbedingt zu ihrem Vorteil,
wenn jetzt eine große Killer-App rauskommt,
die eine Web-App ist und die leider nur
in Chromium oder in
Firefox läuft und Safari es lange nicht schafft,
dahinterher zu ziehen. Ich möchte das jetzt
ungern verteidigen, aber zum einen warten sie natürlich,
dass Dinge wirklich etabliert sind, was schwer ist,
also sie sind halt nicht der Big Player, aber
Dinge sind selten etabliert, wenn
große Browser wie Safari, Firefox und
Chrome nicht dahinter stehen. Und zum anderen habe ich noch nie
eine Killer-Web-App gesehen,
die auf so heißen Scheiß selbst das Safari das nicht kann.
Ich habe auch letztens einen sehr interessanten Artikel darüber gelesen,
wie QA bei Apple gemacht wird.
Das muss wohl noch ziemliche Steinzeit sein.
Ich glaube, wenn die da anfangen würden, vorne wegzulaufen,
dann hätten die da auch mehr Qualitätsprobleme.
Und das ist auch so eine Sache, die mir dieses Jahr gefühlt auch,
also ist auf jeden Fall ein Gefühl, belegen kann ich das nicht,
die mir irgendwie bei Firefox extrem aufgefallen ist,
dass ich da dieses Jahr ganz oft über Dinge gestolpert bin,
wo ich dachte, hoppla, wieso funktioniert denn das jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr
oder wieso funktioniert jetzt das nicht?
Was dann irgendwie so nach ein, zwei Updates später dann irgendwie ging.
Aber es ist mir irgendwie dieses Jahr gehäuft aufgefallen von Firefox.
Zum Beispiel?
Dass nach irgendeinem Update zum Beispiel YouTube erstmal irgendwie eine Version lang
nicht Videos abspielen wollte
oder nicht zuverlässig Videos abspielen wollte bei mir
oder dass einfach bestimmte Seiten
gar nicht mehr geladen haben.
Also wenn es jetzt YouTube ist,
was irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert,
dann würde ich ja tendenziell erst mal YouTube die Schulden schieben.
Das ist ja dokumentiert,
dass die Chrome strategisch bevorzugen.
Da gab es ja auch diesen Edge-Zwischenfall,
dass sie diesen transparenten Diff
vor den Videoplayer geschoben haben, um die Hardware-Beschleunigung
zu unterbinden.
Es ist halt genau das Thema,
das hat es wie in der letzten oder vorletzten Folge mal angeschnitten,
das Web ist, also Google-Seiten sind kein Internet,
Google-Seiten sind
entsprechende propriäres Protokoll mit Chrome
mittlerweile, also
jetzt hier ein.
Also Chrome ist eigentlich kein, oder Chromium,
ich share die beiden bewusst über einen
Kamm, also Chromium ist eigentlich kein Webbrowser,
sondern Chromium hat jemand,
bei mir in der Firma gibt es ja
eine Web-Version
von unserer Anwendung und eine
Native Client
und irgendjemand bei mir in der Firma hatte
zum Spaß mal, und ich fand das sehr passend,
Chrome als den Google Native Client
bezeichnet.
Echt? Ja, das ist so.
Das heißt, du installierst dir da ein Programm, mit dem du dann die Google
Produkte benutzen kannst.
Du benutzt
keine, nicht unbedingt Standard-Protokolle,
du benutzt nicht unbedingt Standard-Web,
du benutzt nicht unbedingt Standard-JavaScript,
sondern das, was Chrome ganz cool finde.
Da sind auch viele coole Sachen dabei, die dann eventually den Weg in den Webstandard finden,
jetzt so mit der Entwicklung von HTTP 3 zum Beispiel oder HTTP 2 vorher bereits auch schon,
das sind so Sachen, aber die halt Google lange Zeit einfach so in Chrome einfach so benutzt,
weil sie einfach beide Enden der Webclient und so ihre Infrastruktur in der Hand haben.
Und das ist schon, da kann man jetzt überlegen, das ist halt schon ein sehr asymmetrisches Verhältnis im Vergleich zu anderen Teilen.
Man fragt sich da auch, wie weit sie das vielleicht auch treiben würden, wenn dann nicht im Zweifel irgendwie mal ein Verbraucherschutzministerium oder irgendwie ein Kartellamt einschreiben würde.
sagen könntest, du benutzt bereits
seit drei Jahren, wenn du
Google.com mit einem Chrome
ansurfst, benutzt du kein normales
HTTP mehr, sondern sie sprechen halt
ihr erst Speedy
und dann HTTP 2, was
lange Zeit die einzigen waren,
die das hatten und
es ist schon in gewisser Weise ein Wettbewerbsvorteil.
Ob es unfair ist, weiß ich nicht, weil sie haben ja auch die Arbeit
reingesteckt, aber es ist halt definitiv
nicht Web.
Und jemand, der mit einem anderen Browser auf diese
Webseite geht oder jemand, der mit einem Chrome
einen anderen Suchanbieter geht,
hat halt auf jeden Fall, egal wie viel
Performance auf der anderen Seite
vom Server ist, ein schlechtere
Erfahrung. Ja und die Gefahr, die da
eben dann auch mitschwebt, also aber wie
gesagt, da sind wir wieder bei Verbraucherschutz und
Kartellamt und sowas,
die haben, was für einen Marktanteil mittlerweile?
90% oder sowas?
Kann das sein?
Weißt du, da könnten sie ja auch
mal auf die Idee kommen zu sagen,
die anderen 10%,
die machen wir jetzt mal
Internet aus, sie sollen sich auch mal in Chrome installieren.
Na mal gucken, was dann
passiert, wenn
die EU irgendwie vielleicht
doch mal auf die Idee kommt,
die Wirren vor der Forderung der Politiker
umzusetzen, zu sagen, Google muss jetzt
zerschlagen werden und die Suchmaschine muss jetzt zu
zwei Suchmaschinen werden. Also das wird
nochmal spannend. Nicht in dem
Sinne, was das jetzt
technisch aussagt, sondern was eher aussagt
darüber, wie Politiker über Technik denken.
Ja. Wenn dann diese
Zerschlagung dann wie konkret...
Ich glaube, da musst du noch ein bisschen jüngere
Politiker wählen. Aber es ist halt
in der Tat auch ein sehr spannendes Problem,
weil das ist halt ein
Plattformmarkt. Das siehst du an Google,
das siehst du an Amazon, das siehst du an Microsoft.
Diese Plattformen
können nur durch diesen Scale
funktionieren.
Zumindest auf diesem Level
von Effizienz. Genau, oder Facebook,
genau das Gleiche. Und wie fängst
du jetzt an, sowas sinnvoll
zu regulieren, dass das irgendwie
für alle sinnvoll ist? Und
da klingt erstmal eine Zerschlagung
einfach, dass das
natürlich technisch gesehen Schwachsinn ist.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig.
Aber die Frage ist halt,
wie willst du es wirklich machen? Und ich glaube,
dafür hat keiner eine wirklich gute Idee.
Also ich hätte ja gerne eine Suchmaschine, die einfach
ein ganz normales Business ist,
was nicht so verkoppelt ist mit diesem Anzeigen-
Business, sondern was halt einfach ist,
du zahlst halt jetzt 5 Euro im Monat Gebühren,
dann kannst du die nutzen. Das hätte natürlich
dann den Nachteil, dass man da natürlich eingeloggt sein muss,
aber das wäre
eventuell ein Modell. Ja, aber
dann musst du dieses Modell, glaube ich,
auf das ganze Internet im Wesentlichen
übertragen. Dann entscheiden sich, glaube ich,
die Leute eher dazu, es nicht zu benutzen.
Ja, genau, das ist, glaube ich, das Ding.
Also du wirst wahrscheinlich A-Schwierigkeiten haben,
dann wirklich Nutzer zu finden.
Das App.net-Modell, das hat damals schon
nicht funktioniert. Dann kommst du wieder in die Frage rein,
wie wickelst du Payment ab,
wenn du das in Webmaster?
Ja, und dann führst du damit ja aber auch wieder so ein Zweiklassen
dann halt einen, weißt du? Ja, aussieht über Sofortüberweisung,
ist doch ganz klar.
4ST2.
Nur echt mit drei Tenden-Generatorn.
Nee, also,
mein Frühjahr ging das, als wir noch Telefone
hatten, da konnte man einfach so
in Anführungszeichen Premium-Dienst anrufen und das
wurde halt über die Telefonrechnung abgerechnet.
Die haben dann halt irgendeinen Mondpreis aufgerufen
und das stand halt auf der Telefonrechnung und das habe ich halt
bezahlt. Ihr argumentiert jetzt wirklich
für ein bezahltes
Zweiklassentwende? Nee, um Gottes Willen, also
das fände ich auch eher fatal,
als Zeichen. Das ist ja quasi
gebrochene Netzleute. Es geht prinzipiell
um transparente Geschäftsmodelle.
Genau.
Und ja, keine Ahnung, wie man das
umsetzt. Das ist ein schwieriges Thema. Ich meine,
wir sehen Ad-Driven-Business, wir sehen
Nutzerdaten, die verkauft werden.
Wir sehen beides, Services.
Das ist alles schwierig. Ja, alles drauf.
Einmal gibt es auch... Es gibt andere Modelle,
aber die skalieren nicht so richtig. Also es gibt
ja sowas wie Patreon und so, aber
das skaliert halt nicht auf eine Größenordnung eines Google.
Das skaliert auch nicht auf die Größenordnung einer
Was skalieren würde, aber da ist schlicht und einfach das Problem,
unser Planet ist halt einmal einfach unterteilt in 100 irgendwas Länder und verschiedenste Interessen.
Du könntest ja auch sagen, ja gut, dann finanzieren wir das über Steuer
und betrachten das als Grundinfrastruktur.
Kannst du auch machen, aber wie kriegst du das jetzt wieder weltweit zu funktionieren?
seine eigene Suchmaschine und dann findest du halt
nur Sachen aus deinem Land.
Oder es wird halt so ein
Zombie wie so eine
ITU draus oder sowas.
Das fand ich ja auch
ein spannender Kommentar zu der Artikel 13
Frage, wo es halt die ganze Zeit
diese Diskussion war, ob Uploadfilter überhaupt
möglich sind und sowas.
Da hatte jemand mal die Vermutung geäußert,
dass halt vielleicht die dann auch so
die Politiker, die das irgendwie gehört haben,
alle sagen Uploadfilter geht nicht und sind
dann halt zu ihrer normalen Stelle gegangen,
wo sie hingehen, wenn sie Technikberatung
brauchen, nämlich die Systems.
Und haben so gesagt,
ja, Uploadfilter, geht denn das?
Und dann haben sie aber dummerweise halt das Marketing-Departner
angerufen, weil das ist halt mit denen sie reden und die so
im Verkaufsrunders so, ja, ja, ja, kriegen wir hin, kriegen wir hin.
Die stehen da mit dem Geldkoffer in der Tür,
da sagen wir doch nicht nein, ist ja ganz klar.
Ihr wollt Uploadfilter, wir bauen euch
irgendwas.
Ich meine, ich glaube, wir müssen einsehen,
dass das Internet, wie wir es haben, einfach
kaputt ist und wir ein neues brauchen. Ich habe
von einer neuen Firma gehört, die will gerne
ein neues Internet bauen.
Hype Hyper.
Erzähl nicht so viel, ich muss die neueste Staffel noch gucken.
Da war noch kein Spoiler drin.
Aber danke, dass du mich gestoppt hast.
Ist sehr gut, kein Empfehlen.
Okay, also wir fassen zusammen,
das Internet ist kaputt.
Für immer.
Was ist denn dieses Jahr 2019
noch so spannend, dass passiert?
Ich habe jetzt meine Liste mittlerweile erschöpft.
Ich habe jetzt nach Punkt 5
Honorable Mentions,
aber das brauchen wir glaube ich nicht. Game of Thrones
ist endlich vorbei.
Ich glaube,
das schieben wir auf die Privatschiene
nachher, oder? Julian sagt,
Kubernetes und DevOps sind jetzt Mainstream.
Ja, genau.
Du machst also auch dieses Mainstream auf Arbeit.
Das sind so
zwei Sachen, die mir irgendwie
dieses Jahr sehr aufgefallen sind,
so im Technikbereich.
Ich war im Mai auf der CubeCon.
Diese Veranstaltung war dieses Jahr doch irgendwie signifikant anders als letztes Jahr.
Letztes Jahr wirkte das noch so ein bisschen wie so ein großwerdendes Community-Treffen,
wo man so ein bisschen über die Technik redet und so ein bisschen gemeinsam darüber sinniert,
was noch alles nicht funktioniert.
Und dieses Jahr wirkte diese Veranstaltung irgendwie wie so eine Vendor-Sales-Veranstaltung. Ich bin mir immer noch nicht ganz sicher, was ich davon halten soll.
Das finde ich sehr witzig. Ich war auf der KubeCon 2017, als ich in Berlin war, im BCC, und da hatte ich mal den direkten Vergleich.
Nee, weil da war das halt für mich genau dieses Erlebnis, dass es halt einfach nur so ein einziges Vendor-Sales-Event war.
Also ich meine, das BCC kenne ich ja noch damals vom Kongress, auch wenn ich nur einmal da war in der BCC-Ära.
Aber so habe ich halt den relativ direkten Vergleich gehabt und ich wusste auch irgendwie,
hier bezahle ich nicht irgendwie wie beim Kongress irgendwie 150 Euro oder was ich halt bezahlen möchte,
sondern ich bezahle halt da irgendwie 700 Euro mit Frühbucherrabatt für irgendwie zwei Tage oder drei Tage.
Drei sind es glaube ich, ja.
Und kriege dann das wesentliche Perk dafür, dass ich ein Schnittchen bekomme.
Aber ich könnte ein Schnittchen auch für weniger als 700 Euro am Tag schmieren.
Und dann hast du halt so Talks, die alle nur so sind,
ja hallo, ich bin die Marketingdrohne von Dollar Platinum Sponsor.
Und wir machen übrigens auch Kubernetes.
Tschüss.
Und dann gehst du in die Vendor-Area und die so, ja, wir installieren dir dein Kubernetes.
Ich habe aber schon Kubernetes.
Wir machen Logging für dein Kubernetes.
Ich habe schon L-Cluster.
und so, ja, was?
Und überhaupt
total Enttäuschung. Ich hatte auch
selber einen Talk eingereicht, der wäre super technisch geworden,
wurde natürlich abgelehnt. Stattdessen gab es in dem
Themenfeld, was ich mache, nämlich Storage,
nur so einen Vortrag über Rook und das war so
hier, guck mal, wir können hier einen Jammel reinladen und dann
sind da Storages.
Und das dann auf 30 Minuten ausgemeldet.
Was ist das denn hier?
WTF?
Ich war auf einer ähnlichen Veranstaltung in Hamburg
2017, da war ein ähnliches Niveau.
Da muss ich sagen, war die Kypcon 2018 schon
Ein gutes Stück schöner.
Da waren aber auch viele Konzepte in dem Umfeld neu.
Das ganze Operator-Zeug und so war alles neu.
Da gab es viele technische Deep-Dive-Talks.
Die waren echt super.
Aber ja, dieses Jahr war eben auch wieder so,
Wender wollen Dinge verkaufen und reden darüber.
Aber ist das nicht so ein bisschen der Effekt, der eintritt,
wenn ein Thema am Mainstream angekommen ist,
dass dann plötzlich nicht nur die Techniker dabei sind,
sondern plötzlich auch die Leute, die damit Geld machen wollen?
Genau, und das hast du dieses Jahr enorm gemerkt.
Da waren Leute von Oracle und haben Talks gehalten.
Ey, die hatten überhaupt keine Ahnung, wovon sie reden.
Aber ich meine, genau das, was ich sagen wollte, ist, genau das ist ja vor ein, zwei, drei Jahren,
auch oder vier, mit der ganzen Bitcoin- und Blockchain-Szene passiert.
Das ist plötzlich nur noch Verkaufsgesammel von irgendwelchen Leuten.
Das ist ein vaporisierender Effekt.
Hatte Bitcoin mal Substanz?
Es gab zumindest eine Phase, wo der Großteil der Vorträge wesentlich technischer war und seitdem gibt es sehr viele Consultancy-Firmen, die dir irgendwas mit Blockchain verkaufen.
Ich glaube, das Problem dabei ist, dass Techies haben das gebaut, dann sind Finanzinvestoren aufgesprungen, weil sie realisiert haben,
hey, hier haben wir einen unregulierten Spekulationsmarkt, den du fast nicht reguliert kriegst, geil.
Und dann sind irgendwelche Consultants aufgesprungen,
die irgendwie auf die Idee kamen,
dass man damit jetzt geile Tech bauen kann,
ohne zu realisieren,
dass das einfach nur eine überkomplexe Datenbank ist.
Was, Kubernetes oder Bitcoin?
Bitcoin.
Beides.
Vielleicht auch beides, ja.
Und um den zweiten Punkt mal noch ganz kurz anzureißen mit DevOps.
Du hattest es ja schon erwähnt.
Also ich arbeite ja so als irgendwie DevOps-Consultant.
Und ich habe ganz lange, so die letzten Jahre, hauptsächlich so internal Tools irgendwie gebaut, betreut, weiterentwickelt.
Und wir waren irgendwie immer so eine Abteilung, die halt für die Firma kein Geld verdient hat.
Von daher waren wir halt so ein, genau, eher so was, was Geld kostet.
Von daher war das auch beim Management dann nicht immer so ganz beliebt, wenn wir dann irgendwelches neues Spielzeug wollten oder so.
Und dieses Jahr ist das irgendwie gekippt und wir sind jetzt irgendwie andauernd bei Kunden unterwegs, die schreien Hilfe, Hilfe, wir brauchen jemanden, der uns irgendwie bei Build und Deployment hilft oder wie man dieses macht oder jenes.
Und da haben wir mittlerweile so viele Kundenanfragen, dass wir gar nicht mehr wissen, wie wir die alle da irgendwie verarztet kriegen sollen.
Und das ist irgendwie so eine Entwicklung, die hat so Anfang des Jahres irgendwie ganz langsam angefangen und mittlerweile ist das irgendwie bei uns ganz schön explodiert.
Und da macht ihr jetzt mehr Dev und deswegen ist das Mainstream.
Wir machen mehr DevOps.
Na, Ops haben wir ja vorher schon gemacht.
Ja gut, Ops haben wir davor auch schon gemacht.
Ja, ja, ich weiß schon.
Mir ist gerade noch so eine Metrik eingefallen,
zu sagen, DevOps ist jetzt Mainstream,
das wäre der Punkt, wenn Entwickler endlich mal lernen,
dass Platten voll werden, Netzwerke Zeit brauchen,
Speicher voll wird.
Ja, das kommt tatsächlich auch so langsam.
Das ist so eine Metrik, wo ich sage, aha.
Da finde ich auch krass, dass wir wirklich sehr, sehr große,
so richtig traditionelle Konzernkunden haben,
die jetzt irgendwie dieses Jahr ihre komplette Entwicklung
umgestrickt haben und sagen,
you build it, you run it.
Df minus h.
Wo die 200 Mann irgendwie
herangenommen haben und gesagt haben,
ihr schreibt jetzt nicht mehr nur die Software,
ihr betreibt die jetzt auch.
Tschüss, viel Spaß.
Oh, gefährlich.
Ja, ja.
Und dann haben die alle anfangen müssen,
sich mit Kubernetes auseinanderzusetzen?
Oder gab es da irgendwie eine
Übergangsphase?
Ja, da gibt es
Phasen, also
ja, mit Kubernetes beschäftigen,
die sich gar nicht so sehr lustigerweise
auch, weil
wie und wo deployed wird, das ist dann
in so großen Firmen dann auch immer so ein
Politikum.
Da kann ich dir sehr
lustige Geschichten erzählen, aber das
machen wir lieber nicht.
Das nächste Folge.
Wir machen nächste Woche,
wir machen...
In der nächsten Folge geht es
dann aber um nichts.
Wir reden über ganz viel nichts.
Schade.
Also wie immer.
Der war unter der Göttin.
Was ist denn sonst noch nichts,
dieses Jahr passiert?
Nichts?
Zwei von euch haben ja hier
in den Punkten stehen.
Einmal Deutsche Bahn und einmal Bahnfahren
größer als Fliegen.
Ich bin ja auch mit der Bahn angereist
und ich war extrem erstaunt, dass das tatsächlich
trotz dreimal Umsteigen alles funktioniert hat.
Respekt.
Das zeugt halt hauptsächlich davon,
wie schlecht die Verbindung nach Leipzig ist,
wenn man aus Mecklenburg kommt.
Dreimal umsteigen.
Du hattest nicht irgendwie verspätete Züge dazwischen.
Das ist gleichmäßig verspätet.
Also ich hatte letztens eine Verbindung von Dresden nach Ingolstadt.
Ich musste einmal umsteigen in Fulda.
In Leipzig kam dann die Durchsage,
dass auf der Strecke ein ICE liegen geblieben ist
und unser Zug gebraucht wird, um die Leute zu evakuieren.
Deswegen müssen wir jetzt alle raus.
Nein.
Dann bin ich in Leipzig aus dem Zug so völlig
angepisst, was soll die Scheiße.
Hab kurz im DB Navigator geschaut, fährt den Zug nach München.
Okay, also ich war da in der Stadt.
Bin in den nächsten Zug nach München eingestiegen.
Turns out, das war mein ICE, den ich in die Fulda hätte einsteigen sollen.
Also war Glück im Unglück sozusagen, aber ich fand es schon
scheiß von der Deutschen Bahn. Also ich verstehe es,
aber ich fand das schon scheiße.
Dann wird man ja wirklich zum zweite Klasse Fahrgast.
Aber so was wollen wir da?
Ich fahre ja schon seit
zwei, drei Jahren wieder sehr viel Bahn,
weil ich es auch viel beruflich nutze.
tatsächlich letztes Jahr auch sehr viel mehr als dieses Jahr.
Aber dieses Jahr
ist mir einfach auch von
Verspätungen her extrem im Gedächtnis
geblieben. Ich habe gerade meinen Kopf
überschlagen, also ich habe dieses Jahr
bestimmt
einen ganzen Tag an
Verspätung mitgenommen
bei Bahnreisen und das
nervt dich dann irgendwann schon.
Da gibt es ja Highlight morgen, einen schönen Talk.
Bahnmining mit David Kriesel.
Ja, den werde ich mir unbedingt anhören.
Der Typ ist ja generell der Hammer, was der von
tollen Data Mining Talks macht, aber es gibt
alle Verbindungsdaten aller Züge im letzten
Jahr gesammelt, also wirklich alle Abfahrtsdaten
und schaut da einfach mal rein.
Nice, freue ich mich jetzt schon drauf.
Ich war ja dieses Jahr
in Barcelona beim Rustfest
und da gab es eine geile Aktion
von Rustations aus
All Over Europe, die
einfach Zugfahrten dorthin organisiert haben.
Da sind Leute aus Schweden zugekommen.
Wie organisiert? Die haben eigentlich Zugüge?
Nein, aber die haben so
Die haben Verbindungen rausgesucht,
dass sie gemeinsam dann mit den Zügen fahren.
Da gab es dann einfach eine große...
Ich möchte reservieren im Wagen 2.
Okay, wo genau? Wagen 2.
Das ist unser Fall.
Und das war
ziemlich cool, weil dann kam
wirklich ein Großteil von den Leuten,
ein Großteil nicht, aber eine auffällige
Anzahl von Leuten beim Rustfest,
die mit dem Zug ankamen. Das fand ich ziemlich schön.
Als ich von der Aktion gehört habe, hatte ich leider meine Flugtickets
schon gehabt. Das war mir dann auch so ein bisschen peinlich.
rückblickend. Hast du wenigstens kompensiert?
Ja. Deswegen erwähnt
du es auch im Podcast, weil es dir peinlich ist. Genau.
Das ist Flugscham, nennt sich das übrigens.
Ich finde das schwedische Wort
viel schöner. Flugsgaben.
Das ist gern.
Die gleichen Leute, die
dort mit dem Zug aus Schweden angekommen sind, habe ich
hier auch schon getroffen. Das sind nämlich die Möwak-Leute.
Die sind auch hier auf dem Kongress
wieder mit dem Zug. Sind gestern
früh um sechs losgefahren und waren
heute da. Waren gestern
um 8 abends in Leipzig.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Zeit.
Aus Jötteböhring.
Wenn du über Dänemark fährst, dann fährst du wahrscheinlich mit dem Zug auf der Fähre, oder?
Möchtest du Infos?
Das mache ich ständig.
Du bist ja auch
regelmäßiger Dresden-Malmö-Händler.
Korrekt.
Das ist witzig, wie die Leute sich auf dem
Kontakt zum ersten Mal gegenseitig sehen.
Das ist besagter Sascha,
den wir sehr oft erwähnen.
Und bist du jetzt eigentlich komplett auf Zugfahrt umgestiegen?
Ich glaube, seit wir das letzte Mal geredet haben,
bin ich nicht einmal mehr geflogen.
Sehr schön.
Ich bin ausschließlich Zug gefahren
und obwohl hin und wieder mal eine Verspätung dabei war,
bin ich noch nicht irgendwie in eine Situation geraten,
die irgendwie total schrecklich war,
so ein Zugverpass oder sonst irgendwas.
Das heißt, ich schaffe es oder ich habe es geschafft
und ich finde kein Stück Holz,
dass ich klopfen kann, dass es groß genug ist.
Tatsächlich so elf, zwölf Stunden ohne große Probleme
von Dresden durch drei Länder nach Malmö zu kommen.
Hast du gerade Angst, dass du es jetzt jinxst?
Auf jeden Fall.
Also auch eine Erfahrung, die ich dieses Jahr gemacht habe,
nach Basel fahren, also schon in ein anderes Land,
was an dieses Land angrenzt.
Aber ohne Wasser.
Aber die DB hat es halt trotzdem verkacken können.
Also es war beeindruckend.
Ich bin auf dem Weg nach Basel.
Dieser Zug fährt, ich glaube, zwei Städte in die Schweiz rein.
Nee, anderthalb Städte in die Schweiz.
Nee, nicht mal.
Basel ist direkt der erste Bahnhof hinter der Stadt.
Sie haben einen Halt in Basel auf der deutschen Seite.
Und in Baselbad heißt es, glaube ich,
und einen Halt in Basel, aber Basler SBB,
das ist der Hauptbahnhof, auf der Schweizer Seite.
Wir hatten eine Stunde Verspätung gesammelt auf dieser Strecke.
Und so drei Städte vorher kommt dann die Durchsage,
ja, da dieser Zug jetzt mittlerweile so viel Verspätung hat,
lohnt es sich gar nicht mehr, bis zum Ende durchzufahren.
Wir hören es einfach hier auf.
Das hat nichts mit Lohnen zu tun.
Ja, sie durften, also das war, was sie uns gesagt haben.
Tatsächlich wussten wir auch,
dass sie dann nicht mehr ins Schweizer Netz reinfahren durften,
weil die Schweizer Bundesbahn gesagt haben,
dieser verspätete Zug, der passt uns nicht in unser Netz rein.
Habt ihr verkackt.
Die haben einen Tastfahrplan.
Bei denen klappt das ja auch.
Das war so lächerlich, von wegen, wir sind so spät,
wir dürfen gar nicht mehr bis zum Ende durchfahren.
In Deutschland implementiert die Bahn TCP und in der Schweiz UDP.
Ich hab da aber auch so eine Erfahrung gemacht dieses Jahr,
da häng ich auch wieder über die Bahn.
Das ist ja wirklich, das habe ich auch mal als Nachricht gelesen gehabt.
Der Zugang hat seine TTA überschritten, der wird jetzt getroppt.
Auf dieser Strecke
gibt es auch wohl eine Verbindung, wo er dann
von Basel noch weiterfährt.
Ja, bis er sagt Geilpferd, glaube ich.
Und da hat die SPB tatsächlich
einen festen Bestand von Zügen, die sie vorhalten
am Basler SPB-Bahnhof,
damit sie die deutschen Züge
setzen können, wenn die mal wieder
30 Minuten zu spät sind. Und das passiert wohl irgendwie so
drei, vier Mal am Tag. Ja, aber die Hälfte der Passagiere
ist auf der Strecke schon liegen geblieben, weil die nicht bis da angekommen sind.
Die Passagiere sind liegen geblieben.
Aber was du meintest...
es lohnt sich nicht mehr, da hinzufahren.
Das hatte ich auch mal. Da wollte ich von hier
Richtung Westen raus,
also von Dresden Richtung Westen raus.
Und dann fährt man ja über Leipzig mit dem Fernverkehr.
Das ist halt die einzige Option.
Und dementsprechend halt, mein Zug fängt halt
in Dresdenhoch Bahnhof an und sollte dann,
dann sollte ich in Leipzig irgendwie umsteigen.
Und dann so 20 Minuten vorher sagt dann die Ansage,
nee, der Zug fährt heute erst ab Dresden-Neustadt.
Fahren Sie mal bitte mit der S-Bahn
nach Dresden-Neustadt und da fährt dann der Zug.
Das ist auch unglaublich. Warum?
Ja, weil dieser Zug ist halt ein IC,
der vorher nach Dresden gekommen ist
und der war halt so hart verspätet,
dass sie ja gesagt haben, so können wir noch mal 10 Minuten Zeit sparen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich
Dispatching und so am Bahnhof.
Das passiert öfter, als ihr glaubt.
Was ist das für eine Kacke?
Ja, ja, das passiert.
Oder stehst du als ausführlicher Tourist am Hauptbahnhof,
dein Zug kommt einfach hier und du bist einfach angespült.
Genau.
So, deutsche Effizienz, spürbar am eigenen Leib.
Ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht, ich bin mal von Leipzig,
heute nach Hamburg
und der Zug hatte schon so leichte Motorprobleme.
Wir sind immer ganz langsam nach Berlin getuckert.
Und im Südkreuz hieß es,
wir fahren jetzt nicht mehr Berlin Hauptbahnhof an.
Wir haben uns entschieden, wir fahren um Berlin drumherum.
Alle Leute, die den Hauptbahnhof wollen, hier raus.
Aber immerhin sagen sie es noch.
Die Leute, die im Hauptbahnhof sind, good luck.
Das hatte ich auch mal mit einem ICE zum Glück nach Berlin,
der dann nicht mehr zum Hauptbahnhof gefahren ist,
weil der einfach unterwegs schon kaputt war.
Den mussten sie zwischendrin zweimal
neu starten, also alle Türen
und Fenster zu, vom Netz nehmen.
Fun fact, wenn du
ICE neu startest, dann steht außen an dem Display
die IP-Adresse, das ist im lokalen.
Das ist ICE-Train.
Ich war dieses Jahr im Sommer
in Portugal im Urlaub.
Da bin ich natürlich hin geflogen.
Da wäre ich dann nicht mit dem Zug hingefahren.
Besorgt es dich, dass du mit Windows zur Arbeit fährst?
Nee.
Auf dem Rückweg
habe ich dann noch einen Zwischenstopp in Frankreich
gemacht, in Paris, weil
Freunde aus den USA, die ich ewig nicht
gesehen habe, irgendwie sich entschieden
hatten, in Frankreich Urlaub zu machen
und dann bin ich mit denen
mit der Bahn noch, also mit der
französischen Bahn nach Reims gefahren
und da haben wir dann, ja gut, also von Reims
in der Feste dann irgendwie nicht mehr zurück
nach Paris und dann nach Berlin zu fliegen,
das ist ja bescheuert, kannst ja einfach mit dem Zug fahren dann.
Also habe ich mich da schön
mittags in den
Zug gesetzt, habe mich schön
bis Straßburg von der SNCF
verwöhnen lassen, mit perfekter
Pünktlichkeit und also
ich meine, so eine TGW-Fahrt ist auch schon
ein bisschen was Sinnvolleres
als so eine ICE-Fahrt irgendwie.
Und dann steige ich
in Straßburg in den ICE,
der ICE fährt los, er fährt über die Grenze,
bleibt hinter der Grenze stehen und
steht da einfach eine Stunde
mitten im Nirgendwo,
weil irgendwo eine Weiche kaputt ist.
Ich habe mir so, oh Leute.
Mir wurde mal erklärt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das sogar
Stefan, das war, dass das deutsche Netz so kaputt ist,
weil wir einen geteilten Personen- und Güterverkehr haben.
Das darf viele Probleme
herausfinden.
Wir haben halt nicht,
dass wir eben nicht das haben.
Weil wir halt ein Gemeindepitels haben.
Der Grund, dass
in Frankreich ja zum Beispiel die TGWs
halt auch so funktionieren, wie sie funktionieren,
ist ja, dass sie ein komplett eigenes Netz haben.
Den Kanzler hat auch ein komplett eigenes Netz,
aber das ist halt auch mit den entsprechenden
Investitionskosten verbunden.
Wir haben das einfach ganz anders gemacht. Wir haben nicht
unterschiedliche Netze. Die Deutsche Bahn
hat unterschiedliche Substrukturen.
Personenverkehr, Güterverkehr.
Die haben ja auch im Netz
unterschiedliche Substrukturen.
Du hast ja Netzabschnitte,
die von einem Leitstand
kontrolliert werden. Die sind im Zweifel auch
sehr, sehr klein. Und wenn dann auf dem
Leitstand, das hatten wir dieses Jahr auch schon
in Mainz, glaube ich,
wenn dann halt zufällig alle krank
sind, die da Schicht
haben sollen,
Dann kannst du halt Mainz und Frankfurt Flughafen dicht machen.
Das ist ein Netzabschnitt.
Da waren so alle Leute,
dann haben die das geschlossen.
Das war herrlich.
Ich habe da irgendwie mal eine Doku drüber gesehen.
Da beschäftigen die, ich glaube, 25.000 Leute
in diesen Führerständen,
um da die Netze zu schalten.
Also ich finde das absolut faszinierend,
dass die Politiker alle fabulieren,
von wegen, dass Huawei jetzt irgendwie unsere
5G-Infrastruktur hacken kann,
während man irgendwie ganz Deutschland irgendwie
runterfahren kann mit
einem strategisch
platzierten Grippevirus.
Apropos Virus,
wir hatten doch bei der Bahn auch massiven Befall
von, wie hieß es, WannaCry.
Ja, aber das sind
jetzt, glaube ich, zumindest nur die Informationssysteme
gewesen. Dafür ist die Infrastruktur
ja zu alt, um davon befallen werden
zu können.
Da leben ganz andere Viren noch.
Du meinst, die kursieren im Bahnnetz hin und her?
Das kriegt einfach keiner mit.
Viele Dinge im Bahnnetz sind nach wie vor mechanisch.
Also die haben irgendwie in Standhaltung.
Das wird ja jetzt besser.
Also auf der neuen Schnellfahrstrecke zwischen Leipzig und Erfurt
ist nur noch ETCS-Signalisierung.
Also da brauchst du zwingend ETCS im Rückkanal.
Das erinnert mich an.
Ja, das ist die Zukunft.
Wir sind nämlich an einen tollen Podcast.
Ja, aber das restliche Bahnnetz musst du ja erstmal ins 20. Jahrhundert holen,
bevor du es uns 21 zuschauen kannst.
Wir sind in Ostern immer noch dabei,
die fehlenden Zweifgleise nachzurüsten,
die die Sowjets damals abmontiert haben.
Hallo, wir bauen auch selber noch ab.
Wir sind bei Sowjets angekommen.
Wollen wir das nicht mehr wechseln?
Eigentlich wollte ich ja nochmal weiter wechseln,
weil bei mir geht es genau anders rum.
Eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich das aufgebracht habe,
war eigentlich, weil ich eine positive Nachricht
verbringen wollte.
Und das ist A.
Nicht gelungen.
Man kann, ich weiß, man kann tatsächlich in andere Länder mit der Bahn reisen, auch regelmäßig, das funktioniert.
Und man kann das sogar günstig machen, erstaunlicherweise.
Also mit so einer Bahncard 25, wenn man das früh genug bucht und so eine Dienstreise, die man regelmäßig macht, weiß man ja früh genug.
Für 100 Euro oder 110 Euro hin und zurück Dresden-Malmel ist kein Ding.
Das kann ich tatsächlich auch positiv herausstellen.
Ich habe geguckt, beim Dezember ist es ja so, wenn man jetzt so zum Kongress bucht, da kommt ja noch erschwerend hinzu.
Normalerweise kannst du drei Monate vorher buchen.
Und da müsstest du halt natürlich idealerweise halt drei Monate vor der Hinfahrt gucken und drei Monate vor der Rückfahrt oder sowas.
Kommt doch nicht der Fahrplanwechsel davor.
Das ist eben der Punkt im Dezember, ist der Fahrplanwechsel.
Und deswegen ist dann das Buchen erst zwei Monate vorher möglich, zwei Monate vor dem Fahrplanwechsel.
Das war dann halt in dem Fall der 15. Oktober.
Das heißt, ich hatte mir dann schon langfristig geplant, dann einen Termin in den Kalender gesetzt.
15. Oktober, 10 Uhr,
Bahntickets buchen.
Und bei mir ist es halt noch eine etwas komplizierterer
Flügelfahrt. Also ich bin
gefahren erstmal von Dresden zu meinen Eltern
nach Mecklenburg. Dann
nach Weihnachten dann hier runter, nach Leipzig
zum Kongress. Nach Leipzig, wenn der Kongress
vorbei ist, dann noch zu einem Bekannten in Westdeutschland
um Silvester zu feiern und danach
wieder zurück nach Dresden. Also vier Fahrten insgesamt.
Und ich habe tatsächlich alle,
inklusive Reservierung und sogar eine Fahrt in der
ersten Klasse gebucht für 120 Euro.
Das wäre nicht schlecht.
Man muss halt nur wirklich am allerersten Tag sofort klicken.
Du brauchst aber auch eine Bahncard, sonst ist es halt echt irgendwie zu teuer.
Ich habe die 25er zur Zeit.
Ich möchte noch eine Empfehlung aussprechen für den tollen Service Bahn.guru.
Oh ja, danke.
Entwickelt von, wie heißt das, komme ich gerade nicht auf den Land.
Es ist aber auch hier irgendwo gerade um die Ecke, wo auch immer...
Das war eine U-Bahn, oder?
Nee, nee, nee.
Das Einzige, was du tun müsstest, um Deutschland komplett runterzufahren,
ist einfach irgendwie einen Nuke auf dieses Gebäude jetzt gerade werfen.
dann ist Deutschland runtergefahren, was IT angeht.
Und heutzutage ist alles IT.
Deutschland ist runtergefahren.
Ich finde es gefährlich.
Bitte sitzen da keine Leute irgendwelche Klausen in dem Kopf.
Mir geht es nämlich zum Beispiel genau andersrum mit den Bahnen.
Eigentlich könnte ich ja mit der Bahn auf Arbeit fahren.
Du pendelst regelmäßig nach Westdeutschland.
Richtig.
Und tatsächlich mit dem Zug, mit dem ich heute früh gefahren bin,
der fährt nach Köln rüber.
Das ist schon fast die ganze Strecke.
Der fährt leider nur 6-7 Stunden oder so.
Und deswegen geht es halt nicht leider.
Ich bin deswegen gezwungen quasi zu fliegen, was nur 50 Minuten dauert für fast dieselbe Strecke.
Plus Zeit zum Flughafen oder auf der anderen Seite auch vom Flughafen zum Arbeiten?
Nee, 50 Minuten über Luft.
Das kommt dazu, aber ich habe eine Dienstreise mehrmals auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise gemacht von Dresden nach Karlsruhe.
Und der Benchmark war, mit der Bahn dauert die gesamte Reise vom Bahnhof zu Bahnhof sechs Stunden.
und mit dem Flugzeug plus,
das geht ja bloß bis Frankfurt
und dann einen Leihwagen nehmen oder
einen Zug weiterfahren, Wurst, hast du
fünf Stunden gebraucht mit Warten im
Sicherheitsbereich, vorher anreisen,
um einzuchecken,
dann dein Zeugs vom Band holen
und die gesamte Orga rundherum.
Und dafür bist du, wenn du fliegst,
dann die gesamte Zeit beschäftigt und wenn du im Zug sitzt,
kannst du einfach mal,
das setzt dich rein und steigst nach sechs Stunden
wieder aus und hast zwischendurch auch was Produktives gemacht.
Das ist aber nicht so polarisierend zu sagen,
das ist halt auch eine Übungssache.
Ja. Also bei mir ist es
halt auch eine Übungssache.
Also bei mir ist es halt so zweieinhalb Stunden
oder so von Tür zu Tür
mit allem drum und dran und
dann baut man schon am Gepäck rum und weiß ganz genau,
wann man da sein muss.
Da kann das einen großen Unterschied machen und am Ende
ist es ja auch, gerade wenn es
geschäftlich ist, auch eine Wirtschaftlichkeitsfrage,
weil im Zweifel
sagt auch der Kunde, für den du diese
Dienstreise machst, wenn du
sagst, oh ich fahre lieber Bahn, das kostet
mehr und dauert doppelt so lange,
dann sagt er dir vielleicht auch, sag mal, bist du bescheuerst,
das bezahlt nicht doch. Kommt ja noch dazu, dass Flügel so pensioniert
sind, relativ stark sogar,
und die Bahn halt unendlich
teure Tickets hat. Aber tatsächlich ist
eigentlich ein anderer Grund dafür verantwortlich,
denn ich bin ja dieses Jahr Vater geworden.
Way Highlighter!
Herzlich willkommen, Steiger hat sich
geforkt. Wir haben noch
fünf Minuten. Fork, Rückgabewert waren
null, also alles gut gegangen.
Genau, und
da ich halt die Zeit möglichst dann bei meiner
Familie verbringen will, bin ich halt
deswegen gezwungen.
Das ist vielleicht halt eine ganze Nacht
unterwegs. Moment, Moment, Moment. Return-Wert
Null würde heißen, dass du der Kind-Prozess bist.
Ah Gott. Okay.
Hast du das Kind mal gesehen?
Die Frisur teilen
sie sich auf jeden Fall.
Die Frisur
ist schon mal die gleiche, genau.
Ja, genau.
Und ja, das ist auf jeden Fall
cool. Also Papa sein
ist quasi empfehlenswert.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Ist das das erste Akronymisierbar?
Gast und Co-Host-Kind eigentlich?
Bestimmt nicht.
Ist das so wie Kamerakind?
Was?
Ja, das Kind darf bei uns das Mikro halten.
Anderthalb Stunden lang.
Ja, es wird einfach mit Gaffa-Tape auf den Kopf oben
und dann muss man das nur in der richtigen Höhe...
Dann musst du die ganze Zeit hinterher rinnen.
Das ist ganz schön anstrengend.
Vielleicht für meine Erzähl-Bibliothek, bitte.
Okay, wir machen noch eine ganz kurze Runde,
weil wir uns gerade das Schild hochgehalten
bekommen haben von unserem
freundlichen Podcast-Engel,
oder, nee, Einhorn sagen wir,
dass wir noch fünf Minuten
haben.
Und zwar, wir können ja leider keine Zusammenfassung machen
von den geilen Talks, die wir alle schon gesehen haben,
weil die alle
noch nicht stattgefunden haben, weil es erst Tag 1 ist.
Aber wisst ihr schon,
von den Talks morgen oder übermorgen
oder überübermorgen, zu welchen ihr auf jeden Fall
gehen werdet.
Ich kann, wie gesagt, Bahnmeining nur empfehlen. Also hoffentlich
nicht nur empfehlen, aber ich werde da auf jeden Fall hingehen.
Bahnmeining, genau.
Ja, da werde ich auch hingehen.
Das ist plus eins.
Tatsächlich habe ich nach morgen auch noch gar nicht
geguckt, was ist. Also da müsst ihr mir noch Empfehlungen
geben. Alle scrollen jetzt gerade durch ihre Apps durch.
Ja, ja. Ich nutze aber auch die App,
die mir dann morgen früh sagen wird, wo ich
hingehe. Okay, also ihr macht das alles so
frei schnauze. Ich habe die App das in meinen
Kalender eintragen lassen. Also ich
guckt zuletzt relativ wenig Talks,
weil es ist halt hier
viele Dinge zu erleben, die man halt nachher nicht mehr erleben kann.
Talks kann man meistens nochmal nachgucken.
Was ich mir dann eher persönlich angucke,
sind die Entertainment-Sachen.
Völlig uneigennützig verweise ich zum Beispiel auf das Hacker Jeopardy.
Was heute ist, oder?
Was heute Abend.
Das kann man sich doch auch im Nachhinein anschauen,
aber man kann nicht teilnehmen.
Es ist nicht dasselbe.
Das können wir noch teilnehmen.
Das Haunted House soll sehr cool sein.
Ich habe gerade davon gehört, dass es sowas gibt,
aber ich weiß noch nicht, was da los ist.
Ist das hier im Kids-Bereich?
Nee, es ist drüben in der anderen Assembly-Halle.
Ein Haunted House.
Letztes Jahr gab es auch irgendwie auf dem Parkplatz hinten
irgendwie so einen aus Containern zusammengebauten Club.
Da möchte ich auch mal gucken, ob es den dieses Jahr wieder gibt.
Das war irgendwie letztes Jahr ganz schön freaky.
So viele versteckte Dinge.
Ich erinnere mich noch an irgendwelche Aufzug-Raves in Hamburg.
Das war großartig.
Eine Sache, die ein Highlight für mich dieses Jahr ist,
die nicht versteckt ist, ist die Fairy Dust.
Die sie nämlich aus ihrem Versteck,
wo es letztes Jahr war, nämlich in diesem Club
am Rand, wo du irgendwie
nur betrunken
reingehen konntest, wirklich rausgeholt
haben und sie wieder schön dort, wo sie hingehört,
in die Mitte der Glashalle gestellt haben.
In die Mitte der Gesellschaft.
Da können wir ja auch nachher gleich alle noch ein Gruppenfoto
machen, wenn diese Sendung vorbei ist, oder?
Mein Konsent.
Also ich finde, dass
zumindest ich auf jeden Fall besser
aussehen, wenn man mich in dem Foto durch eine Flasche Bier
ersetzt. Ja, aber die nächste
geht auf dich. Ja, das können wir machen.
Gut, ich glaube,
wir haben ein...
Nee, nee, das war... Ich habe nur den gleichen Gedanken, wie du gerade
gehabt hast. Ich glaube, wir haben einen guten Abschluss
gefunden. Wir haben akronomisierbar
Folge 36
passenderweise auf dem extra dafür
durchnummerierten
36C3 aufgenommen.
Das heißt, ihr dürft jetzt nächstes Jahr keine
Folge machen, damit das akronomisierbar 37
auf dem 37C3 ist. Oder ihr
macht hier mit Punkten und Monaten. Vielleicht schaffen
wir ja Folge 42.
akronomisierbar.
Akronomisierbar 2020.01.
Nee, nee, mach ich.
September.
Ich hätte sogar einen Zündungstitel, der mir noch eingefallen ist.
Akronomisierbar.
Ansonsten möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen,
vielen lieben Dank an die Technik,
die uns so wunderschön betreut hat
und uns daran erinnert hat, die Zeit bei dieser Folge
einzuhalten. Danke sehr an dieser Stelle.
An das Sendezentrum, das uns
zum mittlerweile dritten Mal
beherbergt
mit Technik-Vorsorge-Plattformen bietet für unseren Shit-Pro.
Genau. Vielen lieben Dank
auch an die Leute im Publikumsbereich,
die mitunter wirklich von Anfang an
dabei gesessen haben und sich den Quatsch hier anhören.
Ja, du nicht, aber du bist
ja auch gerade erst gekommen. Du wartest
garantiert auf den nächsten Podcast hier. Was ist hier
danach? Wer ist der Nächste?
Bitte?
Das verstehe ich leider nicht.
Du musst deinen Kopf hören.
Es wird nicht besser. Star Wars.
Danach ist Star Wars.
Das ist noch ein Highlight für mich.
Star Wars, die neue Scheißtrilogie ist endlich zu Ende.
Oh Gott, war dieser Film schlimm.
Ja, nee, nee, das reißt nicht.
Also, in diesem Sinne,
ich wünsche einen guten Rutsch
in 2020, ein neues Jahrzehnt
beginnt und wir schauen, was das alles für uns
bringt. Wir sehen uns mit viel Glück
wieder nächstes Jahr beim
37C3, bei der hoffentlich
nicht nur 37. Folge,
akronomisierbar. Vielen Dank an unsere
Gesprächsteilnehmer an dieser Stelle, vielen Dank
nochmal an die Technik, vielen Dank an das Publikum,
dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Das war
Akronomisierbar Folge 36
und der nächste,
wir werden es dieses Mal machen mit dem Countdown.
Alle, ja. Okay, wir zählen gemeinsam.
Der nächste Podcast in eurem Feed beginnt
in 3,
2, 1.
Frohes Neujahr. Tschüss
und bis bald.